foreign
[Music]
welcome here to the session on
accelerating Innovation for your sap
workloads on Google Cloud
I think folks are still rolling in but
we'll get started
my name is
I lead product management alongside my
colleagues Mike and sherwick here in the
audience here we'll be running the
session and as you can tell we have a
packed session with a lot of speakers in
fact we're very excited about three of
our customers joining here on stage
talking to you guys about how they are
accelerating their digital
transformation on the platform
now from a ghoul's perspective what we
hope to accomplish in this session is so
we'll be discussing why customers are
choosing Google Cloud for their sap
workloads we'll talk a little bit about
our capabilities we'll talk about some
new exciting announcements we're going
to make here today
we're also going to hear of course from
the three Spotlight customers we're
going to hear from Vodafone
I don't think they need an introduction
they're the largest Telecom in the world
we're going to hear from Indigo Books
they are the largest book and music
retailer in Canada we're going to hear
from Mercado Libre who are also the
largest e-commerce they have the largest
e-commerce ecosystem in Latin right all
of these customers have very interesting
stories to share with you about what
they have done in terms of accelerating
their Journey when it comes to sap
workloads on Google cloud and we're able
to get a lot of good business outcomes
from the from the move to Google Cloud
and time permitting we'll do some q a at
the end
so first I want to take a moment and
acknowledge and recognize celebrate
thousands of customers who are actually
who brought their sap workloads to the
platform in our Digi and our undergoing
real digital transformation
all of these customers you know they
come from different verticals Finance
retail they come from different
geographies all over the world
but one thing that's you know unique
across and rather common across all of
these folks is the
business outcomes they're able to drive
by bringing their workloads onto the
platform just as examples we have ATB
Financial who's able to improve the time
from data to insights by 117 times after
they move their Erp systems into the
Google cloud in the and after leveraging
bigquery on the platform
we have a company called One Network
Express it's a singapore-based shipping
company
it used to take them a full day to get
data into their on-premises data
warehouse now it takes them minutes to
basically load that same data into
bigquery and get to insights we have
companies like Home Depot we have
companies like Southwire here who are
one of the biggest manufacturers of
cable here in the United States it used
to take them weeks if not months to get
infrastructure simply for sap upgrade
projects it takes them literally minutes
to accomplish the same thing now in
Google Cloud
and you'll hear more from our customers
on their Amazing Stories and what
they've been able to accomplish on
Google cloud in a little bit
now one of the things we are very proud
of here in Google cloud is our
long-standing partnership with sep
that that goes back many many years of
tight collaboration between both the
teams at an engineering level product
level and such
sap actually deploys and develops their
applications on Google cloud in fact a
number of sap applications like Ariba
success factors Etc run on Google Cloud
today and the advantage of all of that
is that you get a top-notch experience
for your applications as you bring them
on to Google Cloud we in fact have tight
collaboration between both the
engineering teams the influence our
roadmap and vice versa between both the
teams
Mike here in a little bit will talk
about the comprehensive certifications
we have on the platform
and no matter what modernization paths
by the way you may choose for your sap
Journey on the platform whether it's sap
rise whether you're doing uh clean Core
Innovations with s4hana on top of ACP
btp all of these are very well supported
on the platform thanks to the
collaboration between the teams but here
at Google cloud and sap
of course earlier this year we announced
the partnership between sap data sphere
bigquery and vertex AI highly encourage
you to attend those sessions we won't be
covering that here I just wanted to give
a big shout out to that partnership as
well
now the benefit of all of this is that
U.S customers get to you know enjoy a
platform that is Battle tested by sap
for sap workloads
let me take a second to tee up why
customers are choosing Google Cloud for
you know the digital transformation for
sap applications
first and foremost it's about the
performance and reliability
you know the fact of the matter is the
the The Innovation that you're going to
do on the sap application is very highly
tightly correlated with the performance
and the reliability of the underlying
infrastructure and that's what we often
hear from customers
Mike in a bit we'll talk about the
special capabilities that we have on the
platform that lets you run your
applications
perform uh perform in a way that is
industry leading and your uptime that
you get from the platform is also
industry leading number two is security
we often hear from customers that
they're bringing their sap applications
and they get much better levels of
security on Google platform than they
were able to get before I think if you
guys tune in to the keynote this morning
you heard a lot of good stats on how
Google Cloud sets you know is sitting
apart from the rest of the hyperscalers
when it comes to the number of threat
vectors we see the amount of
vulnerabilities we see on the platform
Etc all of that you get to take
advantage of as you bring your sap
applications and run them securely on
the platform
Lots but last but not the least is it is
a launch pad for Innovation as you bring
your sap workloads onto the platform we
know that you have a lot of business
data in those applications by easily
extending their that data and taking
advantage of data analytics EI services
on the platform we've seen a lot of
customers be able to innovate much much
faster on top of Google cloud and we'll
definitely hear that from our customers
here as well with that let me hand this
over to Mike we'll talk a little bit
about the infrastructure capabilities on
the platform right
thank you venkat
um as venkat mentioned we've spent a lot
of time making sure that you can run
your sap
applications on Google Cloud so what we
spend most of our time is making sure we
have that solid foundation we have over
150 certifications actually it's
approaching 200 certifications that
cover sap netweaver sap Hana business
one and also running other sap
applications like ASE business objects
on Google Cloud so we've spent a lot of
times working with Sap's engineering and
certification team to ensure that you
have that reverse infrastructure to
scale we have 38 regions that you can
deploy Google your sap deployments on
Google cloud in fact we're very proud to
say that every time we launch a new
region like we did last week with our
new Paris our New Berlin region I should
say is that it's available day one to
run your sap workloads so it's something
that we've been working heavily on
so what do we actually deliver we
support running from their smaller
systems which you can see here on the
left side is our N2 family and then one
family so this is really our smaller
deployments for really up to about one
terabyte of memory we certify for oltp
so this slide is representing the oltp
workloads that you run for Hana
we also have our memory optimized
virtual machines which are m1s m2s and
M3 systems so you can scale from four
from one terabyte up to 12 terabytes
and we also have uh solutions for those
customers that need to go beyond 12
terabytes which is our 18 and 24
terabytes in fact Micarta Libre will
talk later I want to congratulate them
on their go live of 24 terabytes a
second 24 terabyte go live this last
weekend so that went smoothly
when we certified the 24 terabytes we
worked heavily to make sure that we
deliver the most saps that you can do
and obviously if you know saps they're
how you size your your benchmark of your
system your s4hana so it's memory and
saps and with
892 case apps we actually set a industry
world record for Intel that we still
maintain we also are able to support
storage and this is something that's not
today up to 7.2 gigabytes per second
with Hyper this extreme
so this basically means you can bring
your workloads and grow on Google Cloud
now obviously this is scale up we have
also the need for sometimes to go to
scale out so scale out for your S4 Honda
systems or your olap use cases so this
graph we're showing here is that we can
scale from one terabyte olap with
multiple nodes together so to 16
terabytes
all the way up to 192 terabytes which is
something we co-innovated with sap on
the first customer you see here which is
PayPal so this is very much specific to
an s4hana use case that's a combined
olap and oltp use case and this is where
they're live currently with 8 times 12
terabyte nodes
in addition we worked with sap rise with
sap
to have their first scale out customer
go live on Google Cloud which is
Mahindra and Mahindra
which was basically moving from their
on-premise system and they were moving
it and they needed more CPU than our 12
terabyte system so they actually scaled
to run on multiple ones of our memory
optimized VMS
and then finally alphabet
Google's parent runs also
sap and also in a couple of weeks ago
went live on scale out
so we also if you say eat our own dog
food drink our own champagne we actually
build Solutions they're our customer
zero and we work heavily with that team
to bring the Innovations we work with
them to you the customer
so we spend a lot of time making sure
that we have the right Mission critical
abilities that you know we get our
payroll as employees make sure so we
make sure those systems run and scale we
also
sorry
we also have a number of announcements
that we wish to go through today so
these ones were some of them were
mentioned the keynote some of them were
mentioned in other sessions here we were
the first we announced last week I
should say a couple weeks ago the C3
Intel Sapphire rapid space so this is
the fourth generation Intel uh CPU and
we're the first Cloud to certify sap
Hana and netweaver to run on it
so this is really built for the very CPU
intensive workloads you have for your
combined oltp old app use cases we're
also announcing here at the event the
latest generation of of our AMD
processor based servers and this is the
c3d based on the fourth generation AMD
platform in addition storage as I kind
of alluded to we are announcing a new
type of storage called hyperdisc
balanced which will be a successor for a
lot of our sap use cases for PD balanced
and PD SSD which is our our low and
medium offering for our block storage
solution in addition hyperdisc extreme
which already was the fastest Cloud
solution native Cloud solution available
at five gigabytes per second we're now
also releasing that this will be
available at 7.2 gigabytes per second
and that's really critical for customers
to have large SAP systems that need to
load data into memory very fast like
maintenance windows or if you have a
Hana restart where you're not able to
reload data from memory you have to load
it back from disk so something we're
working heavily on these very large
systems
and
and as I mentioned we also have 38
regions and 12 more planned in the next
couple of years
moving on um we are also announcing
something which I think is very critical
to our sap customers has then cat
mentioned its Mission critical
applications its reliability we've
worked for a number of years on
improving the reliability introducing
things like memory poison recovery
because you know we have a lot of dims
in these large memory servers and how do
we actually successfully ensure that if
there's a dim failure application does
not crash with all that work we did
we're actually introducing a new SLA
we're going from 995 to 9995 for our
large in memory servers so this is a
great significant leap over what we see
the competition and our if you want to
say are
our work on engineering and reliability
and being able to provide that is a
higher SLA for you we're also increasing
all the smaller ones so if you saw
before that's the M on the prior side
the m1s m2s M3s we'll all go to 395 and
in addition those n2s that you saw
before and all the other ones you run on
application servers all the AMD we're
also increasing that from 995 to 999. so
this is the confidence that we have in
our delivery of mission critical
infrastructure for your applications
and then in addition we also are working
a lot on the tooling for you to deploy
your SAP systems so we have a lot of
terraform templates you can use
terraform and ansible to actually
automate the deployments of your
infrastructure what we've done is also
deliver this guided UI that you can
automatically configure all of these
terraform scripts you can also not just
deploy the storage and the
infrastructure you can deploy the
operating system and you can also
provide the installation files for sap
Hana or your or your application servers
it will install this as well and also
we'll configure ha for you based on our
best practices so that's something that
we spend a lot of time to really
accelerate your deployments and making
sure that you deploy it based on best
practices and from our knowledge and
also what we've learned with running
systems with sap and Alpha for alphabet
okay I've talked a lot here so I'd like
to say let's have a customer talk so I'd
like to introduce Willie to come on
stage our CIO or Vodafone so we'll leave
you join us on stage and share your
journey
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
excellent that video was to wake up
after lunchtime so I hope it was it was
nice thank you very much for the
opportunity really appreciate
um I've got a great story to tell today
I only have six minutes so it's gonna be
fairly brief happy to take questions
afterwards
um as you can see Vodafone is a large
need to accompany talker we serve 300
million customers across 24 markets and
we're on sap shop I mean otherwise I
wouldn't be standing here right so we've
we've been a customer of sap for many
years about 12 years or so and as you
can see we run our finance our ACM our
HR systems largely off this platform and
the story is about our journey over the
last couple of years we've we've also
taken up a number of the sap softwares
and service offerings like Reba concur
success factors that runs across our
whole Enterprise
um looking back and by the way our Erp
system is called evos if I refer to Evo
that's our Erp system we um we build up
a very substant substantial Erp
capability servicing uh 125 000 desktop
users also increasingly mobile at that
stage 31 000 56 million assets and you
can see one single Erp solution across
all 24 markets so that was at that time
I think a fairly aggressive decision to
take but in hindsight a very good
decision for for Vodafone it allows us
to obviously run consistent processes in
terms of global policies you know Human
Resources we also run centrally from
that point of view so a very very
powerful capability
ever despite the fact that we'd upgraded
fairly early to to s4hana and sort of of
the associated benefits there was no
doubt that the organization telcos being
very very Dynamic lots of mergers and
Acquisitions that we had to think about
business agility how do we move faster
how do we actually sell and buy
companies and put them onto this
platform much much faster also volumes
as you can imagine increasing volumes in
the platform need to keep up with
technology changes and then increasingly
we saw workarounds as well
at this stage completely on-prem
platform so one could say if you look at
that slide clearly Cloud's answer we
also built up a very good strategic
relationship with Google so it was a
very sensible decision for us to
actually go to the next step
we got a little bit of a help from the
our chief technology officer and he gave
us a challenge to say if we can move
either to the cloud without any business
disruption we could literally move any
anything to the cloud and that's exactly
what we did we took up the challenge
about two years ago and we started the
planning associated with this very
ambitious program
three very important phrases and the
first phase that I'm talking about now
you could argue is the mechanistic piece
and that was to move the workloads from
our on-prem infrastructure and to
modernize that onto onto gcp
the very more important and more
significant next steps would be to
leverage our strategic partnership with
Google we've built with Google a very
substantive
Vodafone data ocean across the
Enterprise and clearly that gives us an
opportunity to move to the third phase
around cross-enterprise insights and
automation
and and also the associated Innovation
that's so so critical for for Vodafone
so our Focus up till now has been on
phase one we're now going into phase two
and then phase three with everything
that we heard today as well and what's
been spoken about we think our
positioning is really really excellent
so let's talk about the program
um I think all of you have seen this
before as you can imagine it was a
phased program we didn't do all of the
the big complex stuff first in fact we
left that for for lost so you can see we
we had an initial Sprint to do the basic
setup make sure we got the teams in
place we were very lucky and I'll talk
about it later as well is that we have
very very deep technical expertise that
we bought over many years and that
helped us immensely to de-risk this this
journey so our first wave zero was sort
of our tone the water if you want from
that point of view so it was relatively
small number of workloads also not that
risky by the time we got to wave three
which was not long ago about two months
ago that's when we really did our very
complex work which is our 700 interfaces
into all of our markets Legacy back-end
systems and so clearly that we had to
manage that very very carefully by the
time we got to wave three the machine
was well oiled and we could actually
really execute this with zero business
impact and it sounds like a marketing
headline but I can truly say I didn't
get one escalation from anybody in
finance or HR or even sem in fact the
statement that I got from the head of
ACM in Luxembourg he says well he didn't
even know that we were doing this we
should have told them but just shows you
it was completely seamless from an end
user point of view
some of the benefits so clearly at the
end of the day it's all about benefits
the good news is we are definitely
saying our business case assumptions
being met in practice also you see the
resiliency around the availability
sustainability we're super excited about
what we can do there we're going to
decommission in the next two months more
than 400 services in our on-prem
environment which which we we feel is
absolutely doable also Innovation more
responsive I did say that that is one of
our challenges and then the important
one is customer satisfaction and revenue
so you can see the
less than five days in terms of month
enclosure for our financial director and
our CEO that's a really really critical
measure and we can do that consistently
now across 24 markets to get the the
final numbers out which I think is very
important
so some of our key success factors and
learnings I think comparisons experience
and skills really helped us immensely
both from a business point of view lots
of continuity around Finance HR ECM
involvement over many years some
technically value management a good
sensible business case that underpins
everything that we do then the solar
technical Foundation S4 so I think that
was a very good intermediate step for us
before going into into gcp and then
strong partnership and sponsorship at
all levels I have to call out that we I
believe at a very good partnership
between sap Accenture our SI partner
um as as well as Google
and supported by strong very strong
executive sponsorship I think that's a
point of continuity over the last 12
years our FD Margarita Del Vos is not a
group CEO I think helped us immensely to
show us the true north and be consistent
so I think if you put all those factors
Together We were put in a position where
we could live up to the expectation that
our and challenge that our CTO gave us
and I'm very happy to say a program well
executed and we're now ready to go to
the next phases of of really
exploitation thank you very much
foreign
and educational at the same time
I'll talk a little bit about you know
how earlier I mentioned right one of the
reasons that customers use the platform
or choose our platform is for security
let me kind of like tee that up a little
bit before inviting Daniel on stage
where he'll share a story about how they
are able to securely run their
applications on top of Google Cloud
now when it comes to security that's a
very very important mission for us and I
think of security in two layers one is
it the foundation things that you guys
automatically benefit from from what we
are doing on the platform the fact that
you know we have the world's largest
private Network basically means that
your data spends less time exposed to
threat vectors that come from you know
your data being exposed on the internet
the fact that there's end-to-end
encryption by default on Google Cloud
all these are foundational things that
you automatically benefit from the you
know the platform being very very secure
on top of that there are a number of
services and capabilities that we expose
to you to run your applications much
more securely on the platform one such
example is a security Command Center
which lets you continuously monitor your
sap applications on the platform
the other one in highly differentiated
is assured workloads chances are that
your admission critical business
applications uh that rely on ACP stack
are in some sort of like you know you're
in a regulatory environment or maybe you
have data residency requirements that
you have to comply with assured
workloads is a product that lets you do
precisely that without actually having
to select what I would call govcloud
version of of the cloud
you can use the same Google Cloud region
as you would for your non-compliant
workloads and put those applications
frankly under the same account just in
different folders and all of the
projects in a folder that is tagged with
a certain assured workload governance
set of controls get compliance and of
course the other ones in that account
you know that are not tagged that way
you don't you know they don't get that
governance so you can really mix and
match your workloads those that require
compliance and those that don't require
compliance and this makes your
management of these workloads much more
easy and reduces your overall TCO
as a side benefit even if you were to
choose assured workloads for your
compliance needs the sap certifications
that Mike mentioned earlier all of the
infrastructure that you choose naturally
carry those certifications and you get
support from sap and Google for your sap
applications on on that front
today we got 12 plus compliance sort of
governance controls all the way from you
know if you're in the U.S fedramp is a
big one uh both uh moderate and high
itar and across the world this shows you
a map of you know the 12 plus compliance
programs we have and we're always
expanding that so if this is of interest
you know please do talk to us and we can
of course you know we always are adding
more and more uh sort of regimes and
governance controls to this service
so I'm also going to announce a couple
of new things we are very excited to
launch here at next the first one is
workload manager SCP security best
practices
so if you've used workload manager
product already what it does is it lets
you scan your sap application
environment and checks against best
practices that both Google and ACP
Architects have put together in how to
best run these applications in a
reliable fashion what we're doing right
now is to add
security best practices to that list so
in this first iteration we have you know
controls for better password management
Access Control you know we check against
critical vulnerabilities for your sap
applications and all of these things you
get to make sure that your sap
applications are running much more
securely on the platform highly
encourage you to take that sort of
preview service for a Sprint
the next thing we're announcing is the
next Generation firewall that's
previewing today so this is actually
going to be talked in depth in a
networking session so if this is of
Interest highly recommend attending that
session and to get it uh download on on
what that service can do it's a fully
distributed uh globally available uh
service powered underneath by the likes
of Palo Alto Technologies and there's a
lot of AI and ml capabilities built into
it so it detects a lot of threats and
protects your applications with the
firewall
all right so enough of me talking about
security I want to now invite Daniel
onto the stage and how they are taking
benefit of the platform to secure their
applications Daniel
okay um
hi everyone so basically uh before just
going into the detail of security I just
want to put you into the context of our
environment so basically
Indigo what's indigo indigo is actually
a um I would say comparable for the
people in the states it's comparable to
Barnes and Noble but we operate in
Canada
um
so it's a basically indigo is a 1.1
billion dollar company keep in mind that
it's a Canadian dollars so lower down
the numbers a little
um and uh basically we have few
environments from an sap point of view
we have em ewm ECC BW SCM pi and uh and
the Gateway so basically uh this is our
environment we have uh we have whether
we have a Sandbox a QA environment a
production environment development
environment so we're roughly talking
about 65 servers
and I just wanted to for everyone to
fully understand what is it that we have
we're dealing with here uh before we do
talk about the event that uh it Indigo
on February 8th uh it was four o'clock
in the morning I remember very well
um as you can imagine we went through a
huge cyber breach
um I've just listed few of the the
elements in there you'll see that we
lost over more than 930
000 files it was a double exfiltration
type of attack ransomware so not only
did they took the threat actors to our
data they also encrypted everything and
destroyed every single platform that
looked like a storage unit
so you can imagine the damage
so even in our case we have we are we
have both we have Google and uh and
Azure so gcp and Azure and in our case
they actually went in Azure and they had
plenty of fun I have to say uh they open
up our vault uh they actually took all
our all our data basically all our
privilege information and let's keep in
mind that they were in the systems as of
January 16th so about 24 days where they
had the chance to find out exactly our
environment what is it that needs to be
attacked from which angle but the main
reason why I wanted to talk to you about
all this is because
um
there's also some positive about it the
first one is first I'm here to talk to
you about this I haven't been let go
which is usually the case for a Caesar
or a ctio
um but there's few other nice stories
and the first one is where are the 930
000 files so let me just explain when
they took the data what they did is that
they created a Google bucket which makes
perfect sense as we're Google customers
so we add the chance at Indigo to be
able to reach out to our partners at
Google that was amazing this is the way
actually we talked to Google Canada
Google Canada talked to Google us
the idea was to put a legal old on these
buckets so that the threat actors
wouldn't be able to recuperate those
data and they actually involved the FBI
and with all these people around the
table we managed to put a legal old and
up to today the data is still not
available on the dark web which is which
is a really a key factor that helped us
at indigo
the other point that I wanted to talk to
you about is how many systems in gcp got
compromised
crazy enough the answer is none
so we have roughly 1200 servers at
Indigo and 900 about 900 of them got
compromised none of them got in
compromising to the from the Google
environment and the main reason and I
have to to really give a nice Kudo to
both Google and Axia we at Indigo did
not have any experience on this platform
so we relied on our partners to build
that Landing Zone to secure it and
actually it paid off again going back
they knew so the threat actors were in
the system as of January 16th and they
still did not manage within three weeks
to be able to get into the Google
environment so this is just to reinforce
what we've heard this morning in the
Keynotes that the Google environment is
a secure environment
um and the last one that I wanted also
to mention is the fact that
we were completely down
we we actually were down for about 28
days with no
e-commerce website we our stores were
impacted so many different systems so
the the reaction or my reflex in this
case was really to reach out to both
Axia and Google Axia being our our
partner uh and basically the idea was to
say since everything is down why don't
we move to
um to this new production environment
the due date or the plan date was to go
live at mids at mid-march and actually
because of the help of everybody around
the table we actually were able to go to
go live early March which is basically
something that you cannot even imagine
going live while you're in the middle of
a crisis
um and we we actually succeeded with the
help of our partners so that's really
something that we've learned a lot from
and if by any chance I understand that
we don't have much time to talk about
but if you want to discuss about any of
the things about the the breach itself
or the partnership that uh that we went
through with Google and Axia I'll be
more than happy to discuss it about
after the session
thank you
thank you Daniel's story I'm sure
there's a lot to be learned and please
feel free to reach out to Daniel after
the session uh if you have any questions
so we're on to the final sort of third
pillar that we talked about earlier that
a lot of customers are bringing their
applications onto the platform to
innovate right the thing about
Innovation is um it's really about
accelerating insights you know from data
in order to make much faster business
you know decisions that's really at the
heart of any Innovation on the platform
what we have done uh is to make sure
that you get to very easily take
advantage of the other Google services
so you can marry your sap applications
and systems with the rest of the Google
services so you can you know Drive
Innovation with your Landscapes one of
the ways we've done that is to make sure
that we have things like BQ connector
which easily lets you take advantage of
bigquery alongside with your sap data
another thing we've done is we have sap
cortex which is really a collection of
data models these are all pre-built data
models where you can leverage the data
that you have in your SAP systems and
drive much faster insights we also
recently launched above SDK so if you
have developers in your organizations
who are you know familiar with above you
can take advantage of that and easily
build against your you know the rest of
the Google services
just to kind of like put things in
perspective so we talked about you know
a number of differentiators and
capabilities on infrastructure side a
lot of that basically helps you to get
your applications up and running to cut
down the time for sap upgrades Etc on
the platform
you can do that obviously but on top of
that we have a vast array of you know
cross alphabet Services Google services
that you can take advantage of in order
to drive that Innovation that you want
and all of that put together is what
really drives the ultimate business
outcomes you heard a number of great
stats from both the speakers you know
customers so far in the ability to kind
of like Drive their digital
transformation and business outcomes
I'm very pleased to invite onto stage
now Mercado Libre we're going to talk
about their story of modernization and
Innovation and what they were able to
accomplish with Google Cloud
Pablo indigo
thank you venkat
hi everyone
for those of you coming from Latin
America I'm pretty sure you already know
what Mercado Libre is but for the rest
of you
Marco libre's mission is to
give access to Commerce and financial
services to transform the life of
millions of people in Latin America
today I want to share some figures with
you so you can better understand one why
data volume is our biggest concern
during the the first quarter we have
provide services to more than 50 million
people in in the Commerce side and more
than 60 million people on this on the
financial services
all these transaction more than
400 transactions per second and that's
somehow on our sap system so now Diego
will explain how our subsystem handle
this data volume and how Google is
helping us going through this
challenging endeavor
thank you
hi everyone
I'm the technical manager for financial
systems and today I'm going to tell you
about
our sap architecture on Google Cloud
our ecosystem is made up of two Erp
systems
our all ECC
running on barometer solution with 24
terabyte
and our new S4 system running a memory
optimized compute with 12 terabytes of
memory
are interconnected with the rest of the
Sip
on-premely solution
and all systems were Army rated
from Azure in five months with a
downtime less than 50 minutes
as you can see we use two reasons in
Norwegian we we have our production
systems running on running on high
availability
and in Center one we have our disaster
recoveries site
we use Hana system replication
4C to sync both regions
and a
storage solution to move the archive
data
to maintain only three years of the
systems
in terms of advantages the optimized
compute
Network latency that
two lowers better than other providers
and others
Technologies advantages were very
important before to make the decision to
migrate on Google Cloud
um to finish
for us
the partnership with Google is very
important
to continue
working in new technologies in
Innovation to support our hyper role
so now
Pablo continued with the strategy
Analytics
so one of the things we have realized by
operating this
kind of data volume is that when
when the user performed the Apparently
smaller task on the on the sap side they
can easily jeopardize our entire system
so part of our strategy was to move the
data out from sap into our Radix system
data lake house and in for doing that we
are using SLT plus the Google bigquery
connector so by doing this
we can import the data into our data
lake house that precise on bigquery and
easily get from there both operational
analytics and and
traditional analytics and as you can see
we are moving now close to 26 billion
records a month
so once the data is already there in sap
we have to plug the data into an sap
like table and by doing this our
technical teams are allowed to perform
all kind of controls over the data
in sap because we are replicating near
real time after that we also are using
the Google cortex framework as an
accelerator so we can easily transform
these sap tables into a business
knowledge and by doing that we close the
gap between the the business user and
the business and the business terms so
they don't need to understand the
complexity of the technical relationship
between the uh besides the sap data
tables model
by a
by performing all of these we have
minimized the the extra the onboarding
of the new tables from a few days at the
beginning to only a couple of hours so
now even the the onboarding is much
faster the the getting the Insight from
the data it's much faster and of course
that add a lot of value to to the
customer along with the other data
already including our data lake house
thank you
[Applause]